[Musique]
avec votre sélection Gabriel Gontier
comme chaque jeudi on débute avec un
rendez-vous à manilamoau et oui grégoryi
je vous en parlais jusqu'au 6 février la
commune accueille le festival Ciné
junior 2024 la thématique qui a été
choisie pour cette 34e édition c'est
celle du voyage et cette année encore le
festival est organisé par l'association
cinéma public l'objectif de l'événement
permettre aux enfants et aux adolescents
de découvrir des films français et
étrangers de qualité ce samedi c'est le
court-métrage un voyage en bonne
compagnie qui sera proposé aux
spectateurs on parlera d'ailleurs tout à
l'heure de manilamo avec un événement
musical le tremplin des voix la finale a
lieu ce weekend justement de musique il
en est question de votre dans votre
prochaine idée avec du karaoké en live
oui et petite spécificité pour ce
karaoké vous allez pouvoir chanter non
pas sur une bande son mais en live avec
des musiciens expérimentés une
expérience originale et surtout un ver
véritable spectacle à partager en
famille ou entre amis alors rendez-vous
Grégory si vous êtes intéressé vendredi
des 19h30 au scarabé de la verrière
c'est bien noté autre rendez-vous festif
avec l'événement festigieux qui fait son
grand retour ce weekend oui jeu de
plateau jeu de rôle chute de Domino et
même gaming la 9e édition du festigieux
fait son retour ce weekend à Villepreux
l'événement est organisé par deux
associations villepreusiennes la croisée
des mondes et le tourbillon l'objectif
présenter les nouveautés 2024 avec un
accent par particulier mis sur la
thématique sportive en cette année
olympique un événement pour toute la
famille en attendant le retour des beaux
jours vous nous proposez une sortie
prendre pour prendre l'air une sortie en
forêt oui une balade nature dans la
forêt vous l'avez dit c'est ce que vous
proposent des élèves de l'école du
savoirvert le centre horticole du
Tremblet sur mold au travers d'une
balade ils vous feront découvrir
certains s remarquable de la forêt qui
abrite une biodiversité importante la
visite elle sera suivie d'une collation
à noter que le tarif de cette visite est
à votre convenance et que les bénéfices
seront reversés à l'association accesss
sour 78 une sortie donc solidaire pour
redécouvrir notre territoire on termine
avec une idée quelque peu insolite oui
insolite c'est le mot je vous propose
une visite guidée un peu originale que
diriez-vous d'embarquer à bord du tram
T13 pour une visite commentée c'est ce
que propose l'office du tourisme
Saint-Germain boucle de scène installé à
bord du train un guide vous présentera
l'histoire du rail depuis l'arrivée de
la première ligne transportant des
voyageurs en 1847 à Saint-Germain en
lait jusqu'à l'inauguration du T13 en
2022 une façon de redécouvrir l'histoire
et le patrimoine depuis cette nouvelle
ligne merci Gabriel pour votre sélection
une petite préférence ah le karaokeé ça
peut être sympa qu je suis d'accord avec
vous aussi le le karaoke c'est c'est mon
choix